and I was just on my way to dinner with  colleagues when I heard two banks but I  initially mistook for firecrackers or  something so I didn't realize at first  what all the commotion was about I did  see people running but I thought they  were just panicking in some general way  but then I turned around the corner and  immediately saw a man lying there with  an apparent gunshot wound to his head he  was still alive he was in states that  could have been alive or dead I can't  confirm we started resuscitation efforts  we started with CPR first outside there  and we took him into a restaurant that  was close by  kept going at it for 45 minutes I had  two ladies from Germany there who  apparently with medical knowledge so  doctors or nurses who helped but there  was no ambulance coming apparently the  whole place was sealed off in a way that  not even ambulance service is well it  through